this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base
a subscription website where you can
download thousands of medical
images and videos to use in lectures
courses
presentations professional training and
more for more information
click on the link in the description
we'll begin our study of biology with
the scientific method
the word biology is made up of the terms
bio which means life and the suffix
ology which means the study of
so biology is the study of life
and living organisms and the foundation
of
all sciences including biology is the
scientific method
the scientific method is an orderly way
of investigating
and evaluating factual information
to learn how the world around us works
the basic steps of the scientific method
are
making an observation forming an
inference and developing a hypothesis
conducting a controlled experiment and
drawing conclusions
scientists use their senses to notice
things in the world around them
after making observations scientists
ask questions and then gather
information
called data in science
we generally use objective data which is
factual information rather than
subjective data such as
personal opinions or beliefs
for example my car is terrible
is an example of subjective data
in contrast my car won't start
is objective data and is an example of
an observation let's use this
car trouble as an everyday example of
using the scientific method to solve a
problem
in this situation when you're having
trouble with your car
you might then ask why won't my car
start
well there could be a number of causes
maybe the car is out of fuel or the
battery might be dead
you could use an inference to possibly
eliminate one of these things
using an inference means to apply
information
in a logical way to reach a conclusion
in this example your inference might be
that the problem isn't
a lack of fuel because you know you
filled the gas tank yesterday
and haven't driven the car very far
since then
your inference that a lack of fuel isn't
the cause of the car failing to start
may lead you to think the problem might
be a dead battery
you can use this idea to form a testable
explanation
called a hypothesis
you must be able to test a hypothesis
in order for it to be considered valid
and scientific
a hypothesis can be presented in the
form of an if
then statement in this case the
hypothesis might be
if my car starts when i use jumper
cables
then the battery is the problem this
hypothesis is testable because
either your car will or won't start when
you use the jumper cables
now you can design a controlled
experiment to test your hypothesis
during a controlled experiment you
control
or keep constant all the factors known
as
variables except for the one you want to
test
in this experiment the variable that
changes is the battery
while all other possible variables that
might prevent the car from starting
are not manipulated or changed
why must you change only one variable
because if you change or affect more
than one
you won't know which variable caused the
car to start
you can carry out your controlled
experiment by attaching jumper cables
from a charged battery to the battery in
your car
to see if the car then starts
[Applause]
in an actual experiment you would record
any data that results such as how long
you tried to jump start the battery
and whether or not the car started we'll
cover more details on controlled
experiments and types of data
in separate videos
after completing your experiment you can
draw a conclusion
by using the resulting data to see if it
supports your hypothesis
remember your hypothesis was if my car
starts when i use jumper cables
then the battery is the problem the
results of the experiment confirmed the
hypothesis
so the conclusion is that the battery
was the problem
if your car didn't start when using
jumper cables
then your original hypothesis was not
supported
as a result a new hypothesis needs to be
formed
and tested the scientific method
continues
until no more options remain
in review the basic steps of the
scientific method
are making an observation forming an
inference and developing a hypothesis
conducting a controlled experiment
and drawing conclusions